My name is Tyehimba Jess
and the title of this poem
is “Negro Migration 1917–67”
The North lies waiting
with its concrete, hustler mouth,
with electric
boulevard pickpocket hands,
with its icicled breath
of tenement dreams.
The North lies with its clutch
of factory smoked paychecks
and its diamond toothed
stock holder grin,
salivating
for strikebreaker sweat.
The North awaits,
its veins sprawled
and redlined and gerrymandered,
dancing to “Red Summer
Blues” with a pistol on its hip
and “Birth of A Nation” rattling
through its brain.
The North lies waiting
in its kitchenette coldwater flat,
its colored-only
YMCA,
its Harlem/
Southside Chi/East St. Louis alleyways.
It took off
its white hood
and raised
a billy club in celebration
against Detroit/Philadelphia
darkness.
The North lies
guttered in lay-away fine print,
sings its down-home
gospel of pawn broker receipts,
its morning work song of
cross-town subway number runner rush.
It’s got a walk that leans to the sound
of desegregated sidewalks.
It drives a hot road
car bought with cold cash.
It’s got a jingle singing
’bout Saturday night in its pocket,
a fold in its wallet, and a
3 piece suit
that washes
a man clean of sharecropped hunger.
It’s got a black pearl
necklace of washerwoman knees
and it knows how to paint itself
one stroke at a time
into burning trash can lullabies
of doo wop.
It’s got liquor
store eyes full of worry,
a throat of storefront churches
to hum each worry into moan.
It left a cotton
field down south,
along with a warrant for arrest
and a promise to never come back.
It looks
in the mirror each day,
slips into its fresh,
ironed uniform
of tattered hope,
and tells the world how it’s gonna
work itself past everything
it was ever told it should
and couldn’t be
before it struts out
the door,
deep in every footstep
a music it claims
for its own.